For this homework, we asked you to remove dead code.
That is code that could not have any effect
on the final return result of the method we’re
interested in. So, let’s go ahead and just dive right
into this. We take a fragment; if you remember
the fragments are of this shape where the first part
of the tuple is the variable to be assigned to and
then the next part of the tuple is the expression
that is being assigned to it, in this case one is
being assigned to A or A operational, one is being
assigned to B, 2 is being assigned to C etcetera.
Now we’re not really concerned with what
specifically the operations are. We don’t care
what operations are being done. We just care that
something is being done to these variables,
because if there is something being done, even if
it ends up setting them to the exact same thing, we
can’t necessarily know that ahead of time. So, if
you have a fragment of this shape, then we store
that as the old fragment, as the un-optimized
fragment. And that’s the first argument to this
method. And the return is the end return value;
it’s the list of variables returned at the end of the
fragment. And if they’re returned at the end of the
fragment, they’re automatically live, as we said
up here. Now we want to create a new optimized
fragment of just the live variables. So we start off
by initializing that to an empty list. And we set a
variable called live equal to the returned live
variables, because we know those are live.
Now for every statement in the fragment starting from
the back, so we’re working backwards from the
return statement, back up to the top, we check if
the first element of the tuple statement, that is the
left hand side of the statement, is already in live.
That is, it is one of the live variables currently.
If it is, then we add that statement to the new
optimized fragment. Otherwise we fall through
and now we take the list of live variables and we
remove the variables that we’re now assigning to.
So we take all those out. From there, we update
the live list with all the variables that are currently
on the right hand side of statement. We run
through the entire fragment doing that over and
over until we get back to the top. Once we’re
done with that, we check if the new fragment is
equal to the old fragment. If it is, then we return
the new fragment. We didn’t change anything.
So we just return and stop and we’re done. If it isn’t,
well, then we might have further optimizations as
we discussed earlier. Then we return, removing
dead of the new fragment in return. So we
recursively call this until we don’t get any
further changes, because hopefully we can
optimize further. Now we’re going to check that
removed dead gives us what we would expect if
we ran through all the optimizations by hand, and
I’m not going to bother going through all of these.
You can read them fairly easily and when we do
that, we see that we get true values for each of
these. This is a fairly involved little bit of code.
It takes a little bit to think about and this is a
very useful optimization because we can
potentially get rid of a lot of code doing this.